[Music]
celebrities are famous because of how
beautiful and talents they are so it's
shocking when they are caught altering
their photos to appear even more perfect
if you are a first-time viewer click the
red subscribe button to see more videos
like this one today we are discussing
ten most embarrassing celebrity
Instagram photo shots of fake blonde
DeRussy
in early 2016 Ronda Russia made an
appearance on The Tonight Show with
Jimmy Fallon and posted a photo of the
appearance to her Instagram when her
friends weren't too happy about the
picture as a team pair muscular arms had
also to appear leader Ronda was
obviously embarrassed and according to
the mixed martial artist she would sent
an airbrushed photo by someone on her
publicity team without her knowledge she
placed the side-by-side photo of the
before and after picture on Instagram
has apologized to her fan selena gomez
it's not often that selena gomez finds
herself in the middle of a photoshop
scandal but that's exactly what happened
with her makeup artist posted a selfie
of the scar on his instagram Gomez's
fans are shocked to see the wall in the
background over her shoulder looked
distorted from photoshop fans were
confused as to what could have possibly
been altered with her shoulder too large
or was it the size of her head
experts are convinced the makeup artist
wanted to add volume to Selena's hair
before posted so she resorted to
photoshop either way fans encouraged the
makeup artist to share the untouched
photo of gomez to no avail
Lindsay Lohan over the years actress
Lindsay Lohan has had many Instagram
photo shop sales you would think she
would have learned your lesson in 2015
when she posted an apparently ultra
photo of her Instagram feed the photo
shows Lohan turned to the side with her
lower body and the wall behind her
distorted just a month later she posted
another ultra photo of herself his time
in front of a staircase at this time
Lohan quickly deleted the photo as fans
respect to calling her out on her bad
airbrushing skills Mariah Carey from
lip-synching to photoshopping Mariah
Carey does is always present her truest
self to her fans but it is likely the
diva doesn't care what anyone thinks so
was she posted in all to perfect photo
of herself celebrating Thanksgiving in
2016 commenters were quick to point out
the pictures
Blagh it appears as a mirror in the
background is curving up and in while
the cabinet behind carry is curved to
the right
both suggesting that Kari manipulated a
photo to a peer leader Miranda Kerr she
has a body that most women would kill to
have but that doesn't stop modeled
Miranda Kerr from posting altered
pictures of herself on Instagram
in fact Perez poses several photoshopped
pictures of herself appearing even
smaller than she already is in this
picture you can see her performing
ballet move and her waist looks teeny
tiny that is until you see the Warped
bookcase behind her then there is a
photo of the models standing in the
hallway in a glamorous gown that the
carpet looks wavy and altered which
proves her pampers would get another
image of herself Khloe Kardashian
thanks to Khloe Kardashian The Revenge
body is more popular than ever but fans
weren't having it when the celeb posts
through the motivational photo of
herself to her Instagram profile the
selfie showed of Khloe's amazingly toned
abs but the curved door frame indicated
Khloe altered the photo after
commentators called her out Chloe posted
the original photo which actually wasn't
too different from the modified version
Beyonce she is one of the most famous
women in the world that respond reason
it seems like Beyonce might have some
issues with his eyes he has posted
several altered photos of herself over
the years that has enraged her fans what
photo the singer is playing Goff but the
picture also shows Beyonce's thighs are
dramatically simmer he posed to another
photo of herself this time walking
downstairs but fans noticed the stairs
were warped and it looks like the singer
gave herself an inner thigh gap Kylie
Jenner reality star turns and makeup
mogul Kylie Jenner is no stranger to
Photoshop and you would think after
years of being on social media she would
have her photoshopping skills on points
so when she posted the bikini photo of
herself it was painfully obvious that
she was the latest victim of a Photoshop
sale it looks like dinner tried to clone
Sam for photos to make her legs appear
dinner but looking at the staircase
trailing in the background Jenner failed
miserably to fool anyone John man he
might be tricking us all considering his
offbeat sense of humor so we are pretty
sure John Mayer's overly photos
image is just a joke but that doesn't
keep it from being an embarrassing
Photoshop fell nonetheless the singer
posted this selfie to his Instagram in
late 2014 and it looks like he got a
little too excited with the airbrush
features his skin appears so fake that
he almost looks like a cartoon version
of himself Kim Kardashian she may be the
queen of Photoshop but Kim Kardashian
isn't fooling anyone with her altered
Instagram pictures no one can forget the
bootylicious photo she posted with ex
BFS blac Chyna right it's the Warped
wall in the background that has been
crying foul then there is the picture of
Kim looking flawless next to Jonathan
Cheban the only problem is Kim's arms
seems to be missing
the woman is nearly perfect so it's
mind-blowing to see how much she resorts
to Photoshop to fix even the most
miniscule
of flaws thanks for watching please
check out our friend at the hub for
amazing list videos about incredible
people science technology and
extraordinary events we love these guys
and if you love them too please
subscribe
[Music]
you
[Music]